all right the forum the former host of
the beloved children's TV show Reading
Rainbow is once again sharing stories to
bring people together levar burton is
live streaming readings of books and
short stories on twitter the actor
director and educator is doing three
readings a week for children young
adults and adults one headline says this
is exactly what we all need right now
and I agree Burton is also the host of
the podcast Lebar burton reads he joins
us from Lisette Los Angeles levar good
morning thank you so much for doing this
I agree it's just what we all need right
now good morning how you all feeling
we're doing okay I wanted to say I think
a lot of a lot of people would think
this is very easy to do that you just
pick up a book and you start reading but
in fact you need permission from the
authors to read their books on a stream
so you start with a Neil Neil Gaiman's a
short story how did that how did you
pick that to start with and how did you
get permission well I wanted to do
something I have seen musicians and DJs
step into the moment and and and bring
their talents to this opportunity to
just make people feel a little better
while we're all locked down and my my
family at stitcher where I do my
podcasts they suggested that I go for
public domain material and I just wasn't
finding anything that I was compelled to
want to read so I've been on Twitter for
a long time and I sometimes just vent on
there and I was venting about my
frustrations about finding material and
I got a tweet from Neil Gaiman saying
levar you can use any of my stories that
you want and that sort of began the
floodgates then I got a tweet from my
friend and in children's book author and
then the floodgates opened up and so I
decided rather than try and find one
public domain story that fits for the
whole family let me do readings aimed at
the different members of the household
so I know you're gonna read something
from
Jason Reynolds but who else can we look
forward to it in your readings this
morning I'm doing my first children's
book sessions and I'm gonna read Amazing
Grace by Mary Hoffman when my favorite
children's books and I'm gonna read the
writing this wall of the storm which is
the first children's book that I'm I
wrote yeah great choice
great choice I know gales got a question
yeah I do i do levar first can I just
say it's so great to have you back on TV
reading to all of us I'm really looking
forward to seeing you online I think
this is wonderful what you're doing but
what makes a great story to read to an
audience and Anthony I didn't know you
had to get permission to read the
author's book I thought they'd be
flattered but what makes a good story
levar to read to all of us for me when
when I'm reading a story and I get
excited about wanting to read it aloud
but for four I think for these times I
want to do things that comfort things
that make us laugh nothing dark or
dystopian but in essence Gale what makes
a good story to read is the one that you
sit down and read by yourself or share
with others stories have a tendency to
bring us together much in the same way
that music does and this is designed to
be an effort like all reading aloud that
is food for the Soul yeah I get that
Toni yeah I think that's a beautiful way
to put it reading really is food for the
Soul and lovara I'm curious you know for
people who can drag their kids out to
listen to you to your wonderful voice
read them a story and then the kids want
to read their own books what would you
recommend maybe one book for kids and
one book for for teenagers to kind of
continue the passion well for teenagers
I'm gonna start on Wednesday I'm gonna
start with with Jason Reynolds book of
short stories here
look both ways by Jason Reynolds and
four kids
Derek Munson's enemy pie and I can't
just do one I'm also going to recommend
Amazing Grace by Mary Hoffman a
children's book that I'm gonna start
with this morning very good I like it I
like it very low source and those are
all great choices know also in barber if
you like poetry shel silverstein yeah I
can't go wrong
yeah we've had Jason Reynolds on the
show at the time so on
I'm glad I'm glad you're reading I'm
glad that you picked him but levar I'm
curious about were you sitting at home
saying I want to do something coach put
me in what how did this come about for
you personally it was just a matter of
wanting to step into the moment
recognizing where we are and and and and
wanting to make a contribution and I
thought well I can read so let me do
that all right
levar burton thanks so much for being
with us this morning